will Jillian title 42 remains in place
but critics say it won't do much to fix
our broken border it's been a
humanitarian and National Security
crisis since President Biden took office
and it may soon become a political
crisis for him too if it's not already
the headline of a new Wall Street
Journal op-ed reads it's Joe Biden's
border now the fight over title 42
encapsulates all the dysfunctions of
immigration policy let's bring in the
man who wrote that piece Bill mcgin Fox
News contributor Wall Street Journal Ed
board editorial board member and former
Chief speechwriter for President George
W bush a lot of titles there Bill thanks
for coming in today always great to see
you
thank you so yeah I want to read a
little bit more of what you wrote in
that op-ed uh you go on to say were it
were he for once able to rise above
himself he would win whatever the
outcome either he would succeed in
getting an immigration reform where his
predecessors failed or he would win
politically by showing that Republicans
are the obstacle to improving security
at the border the biggest obstacle you
say Joe Biden himself
um you know Bill I know you're familiar
with the new book by Chris Whipple that
says the president is hopping mad over
the lack of solutions at the border and
he was yelling obscenities all around
the White House so what is stopping him
from doing something anything to help
stop this crisis at the border
well I think himself look uh President
Biden came in with an explicit plan that
was to undo everything Trump did and not
necessarily put anything in its place so
the border is already crisis even with
title 42 the communities are being
overwhelmed the problem is Joe Biden is
insulated from all this when his press
secretary makes ridiculous assertions
like the border is not open and then
people see Fox footage of thousands
walking over you know it just discredits
them but no one in Washington press
Corps wants to ask him embarrassing
questions about it so he largely gets
away with it not going down visiting
when even some local Democratic
officials are complaining the mayor of
El Paso representative Cuellar Democrats
saying how bad it is he just his policy
has been to ignore or it to blame Trump
and then move ahead and so far he's
largely got away with it I mean he names
the borders are who will go anywhere in
America but the Border I think she
visited once that's it yeah she's been
to Europe a number of times too but
it'll be interesting to see how much
longer Joe Biden can resist going to the
Border uh we'll see if he goes there
next year I also think it's interesting
that Neil Gorsuch the Supreme Court
Justice teamed up with catanji Braxton
Jackson Brown or brown Jackson excuse me
to oppose keeping title 42 in place or
does Neil Gorsuch have a point let's
take a look at he what he said in his
descent he says the current border
crisis is not a coveted crisis and
courts should not be in the business of
perpetuating administrative edicts
designed for one emergency only because
elected officials have failed to address
a different emergency we are a court of
law not policy makers of Last Resort
speaking of policy making do you expect
that the White House will take the next
month or so to come up with any policy
for the Border
no nothing real look just Justice
Gorsuch is exactly right what we have is
um a health care policy masquerading as
an immigration policy the critics are
right the attorney generals that of 42
went they'd be just overwhelmed by even
more immigration but they're not doing
the job now the answer is really for
Congress to set up an immigration system
that they want one that works that that
processes the court claims faster that
enables people to return those Crossing
illegally but that would require
trade-offs Congress never leads the
president would have to make a speech
make a serious border security offered
to the Republicans and then in turn get
something like legalization of the
dreamers that's what a president who's a
leader would do but I think Biden is
incapable of it he just shows he'd
rather morally Preen and virtue signal
than anything else so I think we're
liable to see it get worse and muddle
along well Republicans do they have the
majority next year although a slim one
so let's see if there can be some give
and take as you mentioned some
negotiation that can take place so we'll
be watching for that Bill mcgirn thank
you so much for your Insight on this
topic today good to see you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight